coffee is one of the most consumed
beverages in the world some people drink
it daily some people drink it five times
a day today we're going to be talking
about all the effects that it has on
your body that you would not expect
coffee hyped
most people associate coffee with the
sudden urge to go to the bathroom and
that is true for some people the reality
is that coffee affects our gi systems
differently and for some it can actually
cause constipation as opposed to
diarrhea and we're quick to blame
caffeine for this urge to go but the
reality is we have research showing that
decaf coffee has similar effects leading
us to believe that it's actually the
result of the secretion of the hormone
named gastric which actually promotes
digestion
coffee can absolutely wreck your ability
to sleep throughout the day your body
produces more and more adenosine which
actually binds to receptors generating a
sleepy response from your body the
longer that you're awake the more
adenosine the more binding the sleepier
you are now coffee comes in with its
caffeine content and starts blocking
those adenosine receptors thereby making
you feel less sleepy thereby making it
harder to fall asleep so its intended
effect can actually become a negative
effect the caffeine can actually also
impact our circadian rhythm through its
effects on melatonin which can confuse
our internal clock it's almost like
having a form of jet lag without any of
the fun of travel
i have a large coffee with a double shot
of anxiety please you can add all sorts
of tasty things to your coffee like
cream sugar or any of this of course
unless you're drinking decaf your coffee
is also loaded with caffeine and while
caffeine can be useful in waking you up
and keeping you stimulated it can also
cause a jittery sensation in your body
causing you to be anxious or sweaty even
that's because it activates the
fight-or-flight response in the body
known as the sympathetic nervous system
research has even shown that overdoing
caffeine by a small amount can increase
baseline anxiety and the likelihood of
panic attacks
coffee can absolutely impact your weight
as black coffee is nearly calorie-free
and actually kicks up your metabolic
rate and in fact as caffeine stimulates
the production of adrenaline it also
decreases the level of ghrelin the
hormone that makes you feel hungry in
your stomach growl ghrelin growl but
this effect holds true even for decaf
because it has been shown to increase
the hormone peptide y y which actually
makes you feel satiated or full and for
intermittent fasting fans like myself
research has shown that having a black
cup of coffee does not break your
intermittent fast and actually keeps the
majority of intermittent fasting
benefits there this means that black
coffee can truly be used to aid in your
weight loss efforts cheat code vibes
coffee makes your hands feel cold
because coffee stimulates those small
glands that sit on top of your kidneys
called the adrenals they secrete
adrenaline and a stress hormone known as
cortisol one of the main effects of
adrenaline is to constrict blood vessels
which are not of utmost importance to
your survival that means all the small
blood vessels furthest away from the
midline of your body like in your
fingertips and your toes they start
getting vasoconstricted they start
getting tighter which temporarily
decreases some of the circulation to
your hands making them feel cold and
look pale
caffeine is one of the most studied
performance enhancing drugs pds yeah why
because it works and has been shown to
have significant benefits as long as you
don't overuse it focus endurance
strength speed have all been tested and
found have been boosted with low to
moderate doses of caffeine 60 to 90
minutes before workouts and competitions
in fact this effect is so great that the
ncaa has actually set a caffeine limit
for its athletes they restrict the
amount of caffeine in an athlete system
by limiting concentrations to roughly
500 milligrams of caffeine or several
cups of coffee
it's no surprise that coffee does raise
the heart rate and blood pressure
temporarily due to the secretion of
epinephrine adrenaline the interesting
part is that the effect has been found
to be true for decaf coffee as well so
another ingredient can potentially be
responsible here it's also important to
note that long-term consumption does not
seem to cause hypertension the thinking
is that those who consistently consume
coffee actually build up a protective
tolerance to it we'll say though that i
have treated individuals who have gotten
their blood pressure under better
control by removing caffeine from their
diet entirely just saying
removing coffee is a double-edged sword
because it could cause withdrawal
symptoms as early as 12 to 24 hours the
thought behind caffeine withdrawal
headaches is that the blood vessels in
the brain which normally are kept tight
and constricted due to the action of the
caffeine start to swell and cause pain
the ironic part of this is that caffeine
is actually found in some common
over-the-counter medications like
excedrin migraine
is coffee dehydrating this one is
fiercely argued on online forums some
say yes some say no here's the truth
coffee is a mild diuretic it makes you
pee more makes you excrete more fluids
however if you're drinking a full cup of
coffee there's fluids in there so it
replaces the fluids you lose right yes
however if you're drinking little
espressos or espresso shots in your
coffee and you're getting a ton of
caffeine in there you're not replacing
the lost fluid and then in that case it
can be somewhat dehydrated that being
said if you're not overdoing it it's
usually not enough to become a problem
my dear acid reflux suffers coffee can
absolutely impact your acid secretion
first of all we need to stop with this
acid-base obsession that is developed
online drinking electrolyte reduced wood
or alkaline water is just complete
nonsense the reason coffee makes acid
reflux worse is much simpler than that
it is proven to stimulate gastrin
release which increases gastric acid
secretion and this happens because of
the bitter taste of coffee that
activates a type 2 bitter taste
receptors in your mouth so the bitter
taste of coffee makes your body secrete
more acid
coffee actually messes with your
medications and it interacts with them
in one of three ways first it affects
the absorption of the medications and
studies have actually shown that common
over-the-counter meds like ketoprofen
which is very similar to ibuprofen and
paracetamol which is similar to tylenol
are significantly impacted by coffee
intake the second is through the
disruption of the metabolism of the
medications through enzymes for example
the blood levels of clozapine lithium
warfarin and several antidepressant
drugs actually were increased after the
ingestion of coffee making them more
potent and potentially increasing
toxicity and the third is through the
disruption of excretion of the drugs
basically how long they stick around in
fact we've seen increased excretion of
minerals like calcium magnesium sodium
chloride and even water-soluble vitamins
like vitamin b think about that you're
drinking coffee you're taking your meds
and it's all going amuck coffee makes
you pee here's the truth about holding
your pee check this out now it's a must
watch as always stay happy and healthy
but watch this there's a ton of great
comments and questions in here whoa
[Music]